we have a voicemail number its 2192
david p very weird voice mail today see
if we can make sense as i see if you
think that this is for real hi david
this is todd smith I am a Democrat I am
a gay man and proud of it because of gay
men like you but I have kind of a
problem well I can hold my head up high
because of men like you you know it it's
it's just tough but I want to tell you
my problem as soon as Trump won the
election my boyfriend to his Republic
Republican has been bullying me he take
advantage of me because he was bigger
and stronger so now I have to let him
have me whenever he wants to do it and
it's just not fair right uh um but
instead of things gonna hump me he now
called it trumping me he pressed harder
and deeper than he used to write and it
hurts what can I do please help me David
yeah thank you okay Pat is this for real
or is it rolling this has to be a troll
ok John Smith I mean come on Todd Smith
Padma okay if it's if it's trolling then
it's clever if it's not trolling it's
called sexual assault and you should
call the police I don't think I have too
much else to add to that on the bonus
show today solar power now producing a
better energy return on investment than
oil half of americans support giving
residents a two-thousand-dollar a month
basic income when robots take our jobs
and much more david pakman.com slash
membership coupon code i voted 17 if
you'd like a discount and please donate
to the indiegogo campaign at david
pakman.com slash donate read all about
it there